let's go next to how about Chris from
Iowa Chris from Iowa what's on your mind
today
hi David can you hear me okay yes I can
wonderful so this is a question from a
uh expecting father myself to someone
who's currently a father uh in today's
you know what you call Golden Age of
ignorance
um some advice on how I mean I know that
your child is very young but how to uh
raise a child with a lot of really poor
influences out there when it comes to
ignorance
um I currently live in Iowa and right
now our state has gotten more and more
down that road of ignorance and uh it's
very concerning and I know you live in a
much more you know much more Progressive
area but what advice would you have to
kind of keep those you know ignorant
influences away while being aware that
they still exist and not being
completely shielding from them so
there's a couple different things here
first of all there are some things where
if your child is eventually going to
have access to Media or be around other
people be in public go to Public School
Etc there there are certain things that
you're that are realistically not going
to be uh you're not going to be able to
prevent them from seeing and being to
some degree influenced by whether you're
in a red state or a blue State because
of media and what is in media so first
of all you've got to be realistic so
unless you're going completely off the
grid in the middle of nowhere
um that you can't just kind of protect
forever I don't think that all being
said
um and this is a really tough thing to
even really talk about but
if it comes down to what's best for your
family I would understand people looking
and saying hey you know Mississippi
Arkansas Alabama
The Dakotas for picking a few States and
saying look at the infrastructure look
at education look at life expectancy
look at the quality of the Health Care
System look at crime look at all these
different things and look at the
countries that are equivalent when it
comes to those metrics to those States
and then you look at States like
Connecticut and New York and
Massachusetts and Vermont and and to
some degree you know Maryland and
Delaware and you say wow the metrics in
those countries are similar to if you
were to live in Norway or Sweden or a
lot of the places we think are great at
a certain point there's there's the
thought of am I living in the right
state for what I think is best for my
family and obviously I'm not
um uh understating what it means to move
to a different part of the country job
housing family all these different
things I'm not understating it in any
way but I think it is a an important
thing just to ask oneself am I in the
right place for raising kids the way I
want to raise them and you know it's
it's a it's a difficult question to
answer in in some cases but I think it's
an important one to at least ask
yeah no I I really appreciate that you
know to just to follow up briefly on
that you know I've always heard you know
the you know you hear The Grass Is
Always Greener somewhere else but yeah
sometimes you got to mow your lawn right
and uh I you know I I truly think that
Iowa 15 years ago was a purple state if
not Progressive yeah and I do want I do
feel like a civic duty to stay here and
to at least you know do what I can to
vote the people who need to be in power
into power right at least you know do do
as much as I can 100 percent
I do love this area but I am quite
concerned about the direction it has
gone in and um you know with a child
coming on the way in the summer you know
that that just exacerbates all the
concerns that I have here yeah and I've
talked to people about this who say hey
you know what I would really like is to
stay where I am and Achieve positive
change so it's a better place for my kid
beautiful I think that's fantastic in
some places what that change would be is
so lopsided and so overwhelming and your
kids three four five they're starting to
enter the world in a certain way I don't
blame anyone for saying I'm bailing out
for the good of my family I not everyone
can afford to do it and there's all
these ifs and butts but I wouldn't blame
people for doing it if that's what they
decide is best for them
wonderful well thank you so much for
your uh for taking the time appreciate
it all right Chris from Iowa let's take
a very quick break we're not done with
phone calls if you're holding on to talk
to me just hang on because we're going
right back to Discord in a moment